we finally reach 10k subscribers even
though similar channels that start at
the same time as me are much bigger than
me but I'm not upset
I think I'm salty yeah salty but not
upset damn you all goo rhythm but I
digress as I promised at some point or
may have just thought in my head and
never said it out loud until the last
video we're doing it 10k Q&A
extravaganza bonanza but before we start
any question I got in the manner of will
you cover X topic the answer is yes to
all of them if I had infinite time as it
stands maybe how old are you I'm a 97
where are you from and where do you live
I was born and raised in Bratislava
Slovakia which has always been my
permanent residence but I do spend a lot
of time in the US so at this point I can
feel like a hexagon and a land of
squares and circles not really belonging
anywhere why your channel name well Emma
laser stands for Mateus laser as it says
on my banner which isn't my actual name
but a lot of people mainly Americans do
call me dad in my real life so I guess
it's kind of my name what's your
occupation mainly student doing IT and
other work on the site if you had to
pick three history youtubers to survive
in apocalypse with who would you pick I
would probably pick military history
visualize because how to put this he is
the most experienced and also being
Austrian he had some basic six months
military training that can come in handy
speaking of military training my second
choice would be knowing better since he
actually was in the US military and
overall seems like a nice guy to hang
out with and I know what you're thinking
cynical historian was in the military
too but he's way too what's the word
cynical for my tastes
lastly I will have to go with cookie
dough even though let's be honest he
would probably be a burden than anything
else but he's the one I know the best
out of all the history youtubers so
anything requiring teamwork would be the
easiest to do with him
how many languages do you speak well
outside of the obvious one
I speak Slovak and Czech even though
they're quite similar languages
depending on who you ask I'm looking at
you Czech Millennials and Gen Z and when
push comes to shove I kind of understand
polish especially when I have to read it
other than that I did spend at the
various points in my life studying
Spanish and German although I was never
any good
it what countries have you visited not
counting stuff like way overs I have
visited all these countries favorite
historical subject for that you will
have to go and listen to the You Tube
history podcast I deal with cogito I'll
even give you the episode and time step
your channel clearly looks inspired by
CGP grey yes yes it is
who else inspired you to create YouTube
content the green brothers especially
through their various very entertaining
and educational crash courses and even
though it's a weird choice Jesse Cox or
as he used to be known MFG katha this is
mainly because watching his videos I
realized for the first time that doing
YouTube is actually a lot of work but at
the same time depending on your mindset
you can have a lot of fun doing that
work in the future do you see yourself
doing history documentaries on YouTube
or doing something else I mean in the
future I would like to be making videos
on YouTube full-time however I have
lately realized that sadly this future
is more dependent on the algorithm and
you guys watching and sharing my videos
rather than me and my actions so who
knows what got you interested in talking
about history ever since I can remember
I always enjoyed watching historical
documentaries all of them mostly Kari
from The History Channel because that
was the only TV channel doing historical
documentaries in Slovakia that was
dubbed in Czech so I could actually
understand it because I didn't know
English back then when I finally learned
English and the History Channel turned
completely to [ __ ] I was traveling a lot
at that point in my life so I started
this routine of always reading about the
history of the city slash place I was
about to visit and this is where my idea
for a history of cities series came from
since I don't really like reading and I
bet most people would rather watch my
history videos about the city they're
visiting rather than having to read it
so and I finally started my channel in
2016 with the history of cities series
my historical interest only grew from
there and that is how I started to do
all the order videos outside of the
cities history series since your channel
is small I'm guessing you don't do
YouTube full time so how do you find
time to make youtube videos alongside
your works life studies easy I don't
have a social life but don't worry it's
it's by design I'm guessing you're from
Bratislava but what do you think about
us Hungarians in the south of Slovakia
from a South Slovak Hungarian well since
this is a History Channel we might as
well have a small history lesson keep in
mind that I'm very oversimplifying
this issue and if you want to know
Morris always research it yourself and
be aware of people's biases also I'm
going to be just talking about solution
garyun relations even though lots of the
stuff that happened is similar to other
areas Hungarians controlled so to start
off with when the Madera tribes came
into the Pannonian Basin in the very
late 9th early 10th century they
conquered the area around the Pannonian
Basin including the lands of modern-day
Slovakia along with the Slavs that lived
there for more information on how the
Slavs got there which my early Western
Slavic video so ever since that time
disregarding few short occupations
Slovakia was under Hungarian control
until the end of World War 1 in 1918 and
this was direct control of Slovakia
there was no autonomy like the Croatian
side for example at the very best slow
acts were just seen as Hungarians that
spoke funny and a divorce they were
treated as second-class citizens that
were oftentimes discriminated against
both politically and socially how are
contrary to some water in Slavic beliefs
Slovaks were always considered as
Hungarian citizens but however did
happen was modernization which is a word
used to describe the conversion of non
Hungarians within Hungary to be
Hungarians but again contrary to popular
belief modernization of slovakia happen
due to assimilation and also political
economic and social pressures put on the
Slovaks by the Hungarians it was a
forced passive conversion not an active
cleansing one for lack of a better word
so you could always speak identify and
live as a Slovak normally the Hungarians
just made sure it was politically
economically and socially easier for you
to just speak and identify as a
Hungarian so many people did and over a
couple of generations those people start
to think of themselves as Hungarians
how are slovakia is mostly mountainous
and it's hard to get a cell signal out
there let alone badger eyes a couple of
million Slovaks that don't even like you
so most minor ization all the way to the
end of world war one happen in the
lowlands
however Hungary was on the losing side
of World War one and the Slovaks that
joined forces with the Czechs were on
the winning side so they had the bigger
leverage and naturally as any winning
country in a war does Czechoslovakia
claimed lands much larger than the
actual area where the Slovak sent checks
lived at this point so Slovakia now had
a very sizable Hungarian minority
and checks at a German minority and now
is itself and doesn't history the
pendulum swung the other way and partly
out of spite partly out of revenge and
partly out of trying to stabilize the
country czechoslovaks busts some anti
minority was affecting not just
Hungarians but also Germans and any
other minorities in the country arguably
the height of these anti minority laws
was the Bennish decrease after World War
two which continued in one way or
another till the end of the Communist
era and now we're here with Slovakia
still having around half a million
Hungarians and one of them wrote me a
question asking me what I think of them
well a considering all of this history
that happened and taking it to account I
think we're doing pretty well at
coexisting especially when compared to
some other European areas and be I'm
going to say the same thing I tweeted a
couple months ago and that is the
nationality and ethnicity shouldn't be
treated as the same thing and shouldn't
be mutually exclusive because throughout
most of history they weren't you can be
a perfectly proud even nationalistic
Swiss even though you're ethnically
Italian or French or German etc we
should be able to recognize and treat
you and other ethnic Hungarians born and
living and working in Slovakia as a
normal Slavic citizens and at the same
time even though you're ethnically
Hungarian you should be able to be a
proud Slovak citizen after all we are
all part of the same country and we
should be working together to make that
country better for all of us shag marry
kill cogito the armchair historian kings
and Generals easy killer kings and
Generals shag armchair historian and
mary cogito favorite disney movie
favorite disney song for movie i'm going
to go with Treasure Planet because I
feel like it's very underrated and for
the song you just gotta go with I'll
make a man out of it right
[Music]
are there going to be any patron changes
definitely not Emily sir well thank you
for asking definitely not Emily sir
there was no special December patreon
video and I also didn't charge anyone
for the December video as I was in the
process of restructuring the patreon and
some patreon rewards so now instead of
paying every month for creation it will
be an automatic monthly charge that I
will disable for a month if I manage not
to finish a video of that month which
does happen sometimes so in the end if
you're a patreon you still pay the same
amount per month so nothing changes I
just wanted to let you my patreon snow
and let everyone else know that I have a
patreon where you can financially
support me for some little perks so
please check it out what are your
favorite video games at the moment
EU for an overwatch but if we had to go
with the video games I spent the most
time on in the past it would have to be
in no particular order
League of Legends world of warcraft
minecraft battlefield called from the
original modern warfare until black ops
3 and of course I can't forget runescape
which was the first online game I ever
played what does your coat of arms mean
my coat of arms is a combination of a
lot of things first
escuchen s question as good child
the shield in the middle it starts off
as a generic coat of arm shield with the
blue mountains being taken from the
Slavic coat of arms and I added the
rivers running down to valleys because I
knew I was going to do the city series
so I wanted to symbolize the fact that
cities were almost always built on
rivers or sea the 13 white and red
stripes in the background are taken from
the American flag because that is where
I learned English and the three towers
or more accurately gates are taken from
the brightest lowest coat of arms
because I was born and live in
Bratislava going back and looking at the
entire coat of arms that is where the
definitions get more generic for example
the swords and the helmet I just added
because they look Google I added the
Owls holding up the shield to symbolize
knowledge because in the end my channel
is an educational one and the widened
backcheck are more actively bohemian
lions I added to symbolise duality which
is oftentimes a reoccurring theme and
historical symbols but I also added them
because trig Republic and Slovakia are
kind of like brothers
and I'm still a bit salty that we
spelled out there's a reason the quote
goes dividing conquer not uniting
conquer but I digress lastly at the
bottom it says gognitti Oh Anita
Sisto which loosely translates from
Latin and to knowledge unity
perseverance do you play any instruments
yes I played a piano
in fact I'm playing it right now but I'm
self-taught so my technique isn't really
any good what is your favorite
recreational activity / what would be
your tip to try out my favorite
recreational activities would have to be
hiking hockey and skiing which probably
has to do with the fact that I can do
these activities as often as I would
like to this means that I oftentimes end
up jogging or going to the gym to get
some exercise even though I'm not a big
fan of either of those but yes
since hockey and skiing have a learning
curve to them and also a sizeable
financial barrier I recommend just
getting some of your friends and finding
a hiking trail near you and going out
hiking with them over the weekend pack
some snacks and refreshments and just
talk and hang out with your friends
while enjoying the walk and the scenery
and I know it's winter right now but
don't let that stop you make some tea
into a thermos dress accordingly and to
be frank most hiking trails just look
much better in the winter anyways so go
go now this videos over just go go
hiking go
[Music]